from the patriots who have been a
perennial contender
over the past 20 years with the
exception of 2020 to the giants who have
been unable to get out of their own way
since beating the patriots 10 years ago
shut your mouth florida 46. one playoff
appearance in 10 years john mara
co-owner of the team and basically guy
who runs the team and in the opinion of
some guy who runs the league recently
met with reporters he was asked what it
would mean for the giants to do what
they haven't done since 2011 and get
back to the super bowl here he is
obviously it would mean the world to me
it's been a very difficult
uh four or five year period uh for us
and um
uh you know i'm tired of
of the losing and
of having the
uh postseason press conference trying to
explain what went wrong and why i think
we're making progress it's time for us
to start uh winning uh some more and
that's one of the reasons we spent the
money that we did you know you talk
about wanting to win and you're
expecting to win more if this team does
not produce more in 2021 will dave
gettleman be your gm in 2022. well i'm
not going to speculate on that right now
let's just see how the season plays out
i
i have more confidence going into this
season than i've had in previous years
so
um
hopefully uh
you know
given the money that we've spent given
the draft that we expect to have we'll
have a better team on the field this
year
in other words gentleman's in trouble if
they have another season like the
seasons they've had in recent years i
don't know that i agree with that
because then you get a new gm the new gm
is going to want a different coach and
you continue to have this
out of sync front office and coaching
staff
you got to get rid of everybody or get
rid of nobody and continue to play it
out but a lot of it depends upon what
they do this year chris and i said this
earlier in the week
any time that the gm in new york is
feeling the heat that's when we see the
cash fly we saw it with jerry reese the
year that it felt like he was on the hot
seat and they went out and signed guys
like janoris jenkins and snax harrison
and olivier vernon threw a ton of money
on that defense now this year
some heat ratcheting up and they go out
and they spend a bunch of money and
we'll see if spending a bunch of money
on you know as i've said over 100
million in contract value on guys who
played a combined eight games last year
and kenny gallaudet and adore jackson
we'll see if that makes a difference
yeah we'll see i mean you know a little
like you know new england and the fact
that they had guys that they looked at
that they felt like they could change
their team they had some extra money and
they just said okay we're not gonna mess
around you know and yeah it does seem
like they overpaid like you said you
you've heard it's you know you know more
than three million dollars at least for
kenny galladay you know okay that stinks
that's troubling but when you feel like
you can maybe make the difference in
your football team make your quarterback
better get you over the hump i think
that's something that they probably
could come to terms with there
they they they're close it's the first
year in a while where i feel like
like i like the direction of the
football team first of all it's because
of joe judge and the coaching staff i
mean i i do have confidence in them i we
talked about this earlier this week or
late last week whatever it was you know
one he's a real football guy you know
the the way they play everything like
that the approach to each game i thought
was very impressive and gettleman you
know even though he's not a new england
guy he's an old school giants guy the
giants and patriots have a lot of the
same philosophies as far as building
their football team and what they look
at there's a lot of similarities there
there's been a lot of crossover between
those two organizations over the year so
ghetto men's
you know
vision of a football team
i do think fits what joe judge is trying
to build with the new york giants it's
along a nick saban's bill belichick
thought and frame of mind as far as what
he likes at linebacker and defense end
and what fits patrick graham's defense
as a defensive coordinator all of those
things so that's where i'm excited i
really am and i think there's a legit
chance that they can win the nfcs this
year i mean when you look at their
roster through and through
it's better than the cowboys through and
through
it's better than the eagles through and
through and then it's washington but we
have an unproven quarterback an unproven
head coach and we kind of kind of got to
see it first
but winning the division the worst
division in football is one thing
getting back to the super bowl is
another i think no matter what the
giants do and now look the reality is by
the time we get to january
teams will be far different than they
are in september some will be better
some will be worse very few are exactly
the same by the time we get to january
though when you consider
packers
buccaneers yeah that's right whoever is
ready for the nfc west that yeah going
on the road and having to beat those
teams now they did it in 2007 they did
it in 2011. that was part of the fuel
that carried them to upsets over the
patriots in the super bowl but that
that's a tough hand to draw but that's
where they are if they get back to the
super bowl it's not going to be because
they're the phil sims giants of 86 or 90
when they're wired to wire great and the
road to the super bowl is going through
their stadium it's going to be let's
hope we win the division
let's win at home in the wild card round
and let's hope like hell we can go on
the road and win the games that we're
not supposed to win i i mean you're
right realistically as a giants fan i'm
not i mean and pete demolitis he's a
giants fan he's listening here i'm not
expecting super bowl i just want you
know a glimmer a gleam you know what is
that the old marty schottenheimer thing
and there's a gleam man you know there's
a gleam it's the weirdest pre-game
speech or post game going into overtime
saying ever but that's all i want as a
fan of the giants just give me some hope
let me see like oh wow okay we just we
got into the playoffs all right next
year's our year i mean that's where i
just think as a giants fan we just want
to see the team going in the right
direction so we got hope for maybe 2022
we can make a legit super bowl run this
year i'd just be happy with playoffs
like you said winning the nfc east and
if we win one playoff game i go that was
a good that's a good year for the the
giants the g man
i think we've exhausted all reasonable
things we can say about the giants once
they start winning games then they get
don't be a hater
to them i'm just saying once they start
winning games if you're right if they're
a contender in the nfc east we'll be
talking plenty about the new york jets
and well our giants and jets both teams
have a lot to prove to land on our radar
screen and consume time in the program
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports